[Music]
what advice would you give
people walking away for with i mean no
i'm
watching this film have a whiskey
beforehand
good advice you're gonna need it drink
responsibly
oh hey captain square thanks anyway
yeah to calm the nerves right you'll be
on the edge of your seat in this jaw
dropping event
right absolutely and don't bring popcorn
don't bring popcorn yeah everyone will
hate you right
yes and you'll be loathed by the rest of
the audience
no talking no snacks right no enough
snacks yeah
this is your rule in general in general
yeah yeah
all right kill next okay this is for you
um
emily blunt and the question on
everyone's minds
who would survive longest in the in the
quiet apocalypse
mary poppins rita
have you seen any of my films it's
pronounced protestant a reason for
tasking an enormous successful movement
i love that character
yeah keep going uh or uh emily charlton
from the devil wears bad i saw that
um i feel
like well rita fratewski
would do very well with that big
helicopter blade she'd bludgeon a few
creatures so she'd do it
[Music]
mary poppins is magical so she'd
probably get away out of it
or she'd kill one of them with an
umbrella
also handy and what about emily
charlton from the double west brother
you haven't seen that i did see that one
yeah um she wouldn't do well uh she
would not do well i don't think
why hmm because she's loud and obnoxious
so
i think she'll do well and she has high
heels and that wouldn't that wouldn't
fare well
so millie what was the reaction like
from the deaf community for the first
film
i think the deaf community is very happy
with it because
well we have a deaf coach on set
uh to make sure that we were all signing
uh
and articulating clearly and i think
that was a reason that they were very
happy about it i hope they're happy with
what we have to offer who is better at
signing me or john
i thank you emily yeah do you remember
what you called me on set though
baby signer you said i was like a baby
signing i did
i did but you still signed so cute
that's my favorite she used to do that
to me all the time whenever i'd sign
she'll be like
oh it's so cute is this miss baby
no cute oh
so for youtube gillian and diamond
you're very new to this story
what did you do um to get to know your
characters
you grew me absolutely nothing
[Laughter]
i ventured into the story very uh
you know yeah it was an adventure
it was uh um an exciting idea of going
on to a film
which uh stories i had no idea um
you know it was a leap of faith it was a
total leap of faith and uh
it was the whole all the faith was on
the uh
based on the first film the success of
the first film and obviously
you know the director john and um
yeah that was where is he where is he
yeah where's john
yeah where's john yeah go on kill
um how did you get into character
killian well i
i spent a lot of time not not shaving um
or showering which was gross no i did
shower come on
that's all very fragrant
always um well we talked to lars
uh john and i about i guess the
back story of of emmett um
a lot of which is you know you don't see
on screen but was kind of pertinent to
this story and the fact that
there would have been a relationship
between emmett's family and the abbots
and that that would have informed
obviously
the relationship when they meet again
but the fact that he is a completely
different
completely different character or like
unrecognizable
physically and sort of psychologically
because of because of the
result of trauma and loss and everything
um so we spent a lot of time talking
and picking hats okay for emily and
milly
how was this set different from the
first film
uh and how is john different as a
director saying that he's not
in the film uh uh as much as the last
time john lost his mind on this film
so he was he so he was altered no
kidding
he was um how is john different i think
because
the film is bigger and more ambitious
and the world expands
um really elaborate big action set
pieces
i think it was much more beneficial for
us to have him behind
the camera just because of what he had
to orchestrate and conduct and
his attention to detail could just
really fly with
this one so i think that i realized was
it was almost more intimate working with
him before because i was often in the
scenes with him and this time he was
very much sort of
running it you know conducting it um
and the other difference is i guess if
the first one
the energy of the first one you know
it was similar to this one in many ways
even though it felt more intimate it was
one set
one location so it was very intimate it
was very
insular um and
and and you know we do expand there's
like huge
new locations and
you know the world is just a much bigger
and more daunting and more heightened
place for this family to now have to
survive so
i do think it has the kind of
muscularity and tension of the first one
but it's just
bigger you know i agree i think that
um it's the the difference uh between
the
locations of the first and second one it
also had so much to do with
the emotional intensity how much action
it was so much more physical
yeah and you saw that in this one and
now it's a family without a home out on
a journey
and you're just waiting to see sort of
what's next uh
um the fears that they face they're
monsters also they're changing
relationships within the family
and john as a director i just felt like
i mean i felt the same way you feel
emily i felt
that it wasn't a big change because we
already had been working together from a
quiet place
i knew what he needed from us i and we
know how to communicate with each other
very well
so that part was already there yeah let
me ask you do you think that
uh are you going off script right now
oh i i guess i was gonna come on
bring it up bring it bring it i just
wanted yes if
the idea of making you know certainly
working
with your husband and certainly making a
film
that originally kind of like uh killen
said
when we were doing our interviews the
origin of filmmaking
is silent and was it
so much more challenging for you to uh
to be in a film in which
very you know it's not dialogue driven
or more emotional driven body language
completely driven
i mean i think honestly for me when i
watch
films the moments that i find lasting
and most impactful is almost the space
between all the dialogue anyway
i find that i'm more arrested by
less in a scene and it's not to do with
verbal gymnastics it's often to do with
space between people anyway
and that's what i love to watch so
for me as long as the stakes are just
through the roof which they are in
the first they were in the first film
they certainly are in this film
i could watch people stare and look at
each other and try and survive
in silence till the sky goes dark
john was very keen on there's not that
much dialogue obviously but he was very
keen on
if we wanted to cut it stuff yeah like
just do it you know non-verbally yes
which was
great freedom and very exciting for us
to do particularly in those big
scenes you know to try and communicate
this
even when they could really just about
whisper to try and do it without it yeah
there's so much to play you know there's
just so much at stake there's so much to
play so i think the dialogue that's what
i mean i feel like
when you're with less dialogue you're so
much more compelled to do
do so much more to convey the
the emotion rather than not just simply
say how are you feeling
yeah for sure it's true do you miss your
beard
that's not the question yeah well like
when you shaved it were you did you feel
a bit naked no do you know what's funny
millie what was this sign that you you
had from me remember
it had something cold old guy with beard
your side your sign name is this gilliam
because of your beard that's the sign
for beard so we gave you the sea with a
beard so
that's that's a little like a little
hairy scene a little hairy
little hairy seed yeah well it was
it was a um it was do i miss it no
and i remember don't you remember that
they had to make like a
fake they had to make this very
expensive fake yes
out of a squirrel which
which we never used in the end it was
sort of lying around
in quite a disturbing way ominously
now i have a proper question for you if
you had to choose which post-apocalyptic
world you'd rather live in would it be
the one featured in quiet place too
would it be 28 days
oh man
i mean i i think um i think i'm going to
answer this in a serious way because
it's the only way to do it i think that
there's obviously some sort of thematic
overlap between those two movies
i think they're very very different the
thing about this movie
though is my character again these are
spoilers
but the character is in a state of grief
you know because he's because he's lost
everything
and you know he's lost his family
the the the the the character in in 28
days later i think had a lot of hope
do you know what i mean even though i
can't really remember it because it's
almost 20 years ago
that's what i i seem to remember but but
again i think
um the the you know the two
what was the question again which which
world do you think you'd fare better in
would you prefer to live in world with
hope
yeah i mean the zombies work i guess
seem to be easier to the creatures are
rough you can't get them in this yeah
yeah they're rough that's why we need
her
i know she's like she's the eye here
she's the weapon i think if i had her in
28 days later
as a buddy then maybe you know 28 days
later it would have been a shorter movie
[Laughter]
i've never seen 28 days later i'm so
sorry
now i have no idea
okay okay i'm not the only one
okay is this for everyone
did you see any more any scary movies
before you prepared for this role
did you watch other movies oh
specifically before starting this one no
no because i i i thought the the
uh
well the horror in this one is quite
different
it's quite uh very fashionably different
than uh you know the other scary film
like shining like
you know yeah what about you
well i remember um what was our
brilliant brilliant
talented production designer called oh
wow gosh
what was his name so he designed
uh a lot of the comb brothers right so
john had told me
to watch a movie i'd seen before but not
for a few years no country for old men
yeah
of course which bears no um sort of
narrative or
thematic uh similarities with this movie
but sort of in the look of the movie
yeah
and the sort of atmosphere the
atmosphere and the the way
it was going to be lit and then yeah and
the in the style of how he wanted to
shoot it and it's a masterpiece of a
movie beautiful
so i remember watching that actually
when it comes to dialogue and music
yeah sure yeah yeah and i remember
re-watching it and just
absolutely adoring and i think it's one
of john's feelings
yeah for sure yeah so so that was that
was when i
watched again um did you see jaws well i
mean i've seen
george jaws is a big influence so i i i
watch no country again and i watch jaws
again but just
because it's a pleasurable experience
for me to watch jaws because i love it
so much
have you you've seen jaws right really
no no no you've got to watch this
you
thank you so much uh enjoy quiet place
part two and please get your tickets on
fandango yes
two two just like that
you